[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
soyez les bienvenus dans ça vous regarde
à la une ce soir cette question une
haine anti-flic est elle en train de
monter dans le pays herblay dans le val
d'oise mercredi champigny sur marne
samedi avec l' attaque spectaculaire de
son commissariat des actes de plus en
plus violents se multiplient partout en
france à l'encontre de tout ce qui
représente l'autorité la police
doit-elle riposté le gouvernement se
donne t-il les moyens de défendre ses
forces de l'ordre on en débat tout de
suite avec nos invités
on évoquera aussi un anniversaire le
nôtre les chaînes parlementaires
s'apprêtent à souffler leur vingtième
bougie la soirée des 20 ans ce sera
demain soir sur lcp avec de nombreux
invités et un documentaire exceptionnel
sur le pouvoir d commission denquête
souvenez-vous andré vallini avait
présidé celle sur le fiasco judiciaire
d'outreau
il sera en plateau pour en parler et
puis notre grand témoin ce soir et bien
tire la sonnette d'alarmé depuis des
années sur les fractures françaises il
avait même prévu des attentats
terroristes de 2015 osons l'autorité
c'est le titre de son dernier livre
l'avocat thibault de montbrial est avec
nous ce soir voilà donc mon programme
c'est parti à chaque cvr n'oubliez pas
pour réagir ce shooter tout de suite le
grand débat
[Musique]
bonsoir thibault de montbrial son merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes avocat au
barreau de paris spécialisé dans la
défense de policiers et de représentants
de forces de l'ordre vous présidez le
centre de réflexion sur la sécurité
intérieure et vous signez ce livre osons
l'autorité aux éditions de de
l'observatoire vous nous direz si ce
gouvernement fait preuve d'audace en
matière d'autorité on va débattre ce
soir de l'insécurité de ce qui s'est
passé jusque il ya samedi dernier à
champigny sur marne c'est votre
département
monsieur gouffier chat guillaume où
siégea bonsoir merci d'être là députée
la république en marge du val de marne
je le disais là où le commissariat a été
attaqué ugo bernalicis bienvenue sur ce
plateau vous êtes député la france info
mise du nord en pointe aussi sur ces
questions de sécurité que vous suivez
pour ce parti françois bersani un
syndicaliste policier sgp police fo va
nous rejoindre dans quelques minutes et
bonsoir stéphane bon souvenir des femmes
dakovski qui m'accompagne comme chaque
soir et qui pour démarrer avec son
billet d'actu a choisi de se pencher sur
une nouvelle arme nouvelle où on va le
voir pas forcément ses larmes des
émeutiers de champigny sur marne
le mortier au feu d'artifice si j'ai
bien compris tout de suite
[Musique]
alors si j'ai bien compris de quoi
s'agit-il alors si j'ai bien compris
mais rien gérald darmanin donc notre
ministre de l'intérieur veut interdire
la vente de mortiers d'artifice au grand
public a vraiment rien c'est marqué dans
le journal en l'occurrence dans 20
minutes un tout le monde peut lire
gratuitement dont il a tu es s'annonce
bien sûr suite à l'attaqué du
commissariat à champigny samedi puisque
on a utilisé donc ces fameux mortiers
d'artifice alors de quoi s'agit-il
précisément alors en fait ce sont des
feux d'artifice assez spectaculaire
assez puissant donc je vous ai trouvé
une petite démo amateurs sur youtube
juste pourquoi on voit un peu à quoi ça
ressemble envoyée il ya un tube en
carton dans lequel on baigne charge
explosive ya une mèche et quand on
allume qu'est-ce qui se passe ben vous
allez voir ça décolle d'un coup sec et à
la fin une centaine de mètres d'altitude
been
voilà ça a explosé c'est joli quand même
est ce que c'est c'est un feu d'artifice
donc très puissant exactement sauf que
au lieu d'utiliser vers le ciel les
émeutiers champigny ben ils ont tiré à
tir tendu contre le commissariat ce qui
donne son caractère paradoxal voyez
c'est à la fois spectaculaire c'est même
presque joly on peut lire il ya pas eu
de blessés sauf qu'en fait c'est
carrément une attaque menée contre les
forces de l'ordre
alors est ce que c'est vraiment nouveau
alors le moins qu'on puisse dire mais
ram c'est que ça n'a vraiment mais alors
mais rien de nouveau un set cette
chronique l'action en train de faire en
direct mais j'aurais pu faire mais
exactement la même il ya dix ans ce qui
ne nous rajeunit pas évidemment mais en
2009 en octobre 2009
brice hortefeux qui devait donc ministre
de la terre à l'époque avait justement
annoncé qu'il allait qu'il avait
interdit les mortiers d'artifice il l'a
fait devant une congrès des pompiers le
116e concret des pompiers parce que les
pompiers il ya déjà dix ans il en a déjà
marre de se faire tirer dessus à coups
de mortiers d'artifice
donc il a un décret a été publié oui
c'est j'invente rien c'est marqué dans
le journal donc si j'ai bien compris
gérald darmanin vous interdire quelque
chose qui est interdit exact si c'était
pas aussi désespérante mesure et
l'impuissance de la république 500
serait presque comique en fait
d'ailleurs pas si vous vous souvenez
l'an dernier en 2019 à
chanteloup-les-vignes un cirque une
école de cirque avait été incendiée
justement avec ses mortiers d'artifice
dont castaner qui était ministre à
l'époque était venu et bien sûr il avait
tapé du poing sur la table en disant on
peut pas laisser faire ça et donc sa
décision s'arrêter quoi c'était de
d'annoncer qu'il allait demander à ses
services une analyse juridique pour
savoir si ça ne serait pas une bonne
idée toutefois d'interdire les mortiers
d'artifice qui est donc était déjà
interdit depuis dix ans par brice
hortefeux
donc voyez si c'était évidemment pas si
d'espérance ça serait comique et donc
puisqu'on a le droit de poser une
question à la fin de la chronique
caceress avait donc dix ans qu'on tire
sur les pompiers et sur les policiers
avec ses mortiers d'artifice la question
c'est jusqu'à quand ça va durer avant
que ça finisse mal quoi en fait
guillaume gauthier chialer pour vous
cette question vous représenter la
majorité
qu'est ce qui se passe en représenter la
majorité je reprends mon territoire vous
l'avais dit c'était dans le département
du val de marne et aujourd'hui ça peut
pas se résumer ce qui s'est passé samedi
soir à la question et revenir présenter
et vous le dis avec un ton
c'est humoristique vous lui trouvez pas
ça amusant qu'un ministre interdisait à
10 ans les stones les mornas aujourd'hui
un ménisque mais non juste le
désistement est dans tout amusant mais
peut-être ou peut-être que ce sujet les
partenaires
c'est pour ça que je suis venu ce soit
justement c'est qu'on réduise ce qui
s'est passé samedi soir un débat sur le
mortier ou un débat sur l'autorité j'ai
d'insécurité mais avant tout aujourd'hui
dans nos banlieues dans nos quartiers il
ya un problème de désinvestissements il
ya un problème de recul des services
publics
il ya un problème d'accès à la culture
d'accès à l'éducation le développement
économique
et c'est sur cela alors faut qu'il
faudrait il faut parler bien entendu au
delà comme je peux le voir actuellement
d'une réduction d'impôt
on interdit d'interdire quelque chose
qui est interdit c'est aller vite en
russie c'est bien bah oui parce que
c'est des choses qui sont réglementés
donc normalement doit présenter pour
pouvoir avoir ce genre de matériel on
doit justifier d'avoir diplômant
pyrotechnique pouvoir faire des feux
d'artifice et c'est donc peut-être qu'à
un manque de contrôle sur ce genre de
marché mais comme dans beaucoup de
marchandises dans le pays sur beaucoup
de sujets vous savez aujourd'hui les
postes douaniers font ce qu'ils peuvent
pour contrôler les marchandises qui
entrent et qui sortent et ça nous
empêche pas d'avoir des milliers pardon
des millions d'armes à feu qui sont en
circulation depuis je parle même pas des
armes à feu pour les chasseurs je parle
des armes qui n'ont rien à faire sur le
sur le terril est de savoir quelque
chose qui est interdite n'arrive pas à
l'être effectivement simplement oui mais
ça c'est sûr regardez le cannabis est
interdite en france et circulent pas mal
dans le pays n'en trouvez pas thibault
de montbrial
il faut il faut arrêter avec ces
mortiers de feux d'artifice seront par
une petite question on va élargir après
ce qu'il faut commencer par dire c'est
que 1 mortiers d'artifices à tir tendu
ça peut tuer donc jusqu'ici tout va bien
trop 20 km jusqu'ici tout va bien moi
j'ai un client qui a pris un tir à 10 m
dans le bras droit
il était brûlé au deuxième degré il a
perdu provisoirement l'usagé de son bras
qui a été cassé etc
s'il l'avait pris dans la poitrine je
pense que le dossier on entendu parler
sur le plan national dans ce même
dossier
son voisin a ouvert le feu policiers il
a raté l'individu qui avait tiré à tirs
tendus
donc on n'en a pas parlé parce
qu'aujourd'hui et des ouvertures de feu
quasiment tous les jours dont on ne
parle pas jour où ça va toucher ça va
faire la une des médias et tout le monde
sera très surpris ce qui s'est passé à
champigny c'est une attaque avec des
mortiers avec des barres de fer et dans
l'intention de faire mal le problème
qu'on a depuis plusieurs mois c'est un
phénomène qui dure depuis des années
mais à une accélération
c'est qu'on a une augmentation des faits
de violences et on a une augmentation de
l'intensité de cette violence pas
simplement contre les forces de l'ordre
notamment contre les forces de l'anp
mais la violence est aussi contraire à
13h contre les représentants de
l'autorité notamment contre les élus ce
qui est un vrai problème mais aussi
entre les gens c'est à dire que la
violence est insidieusement en train de
devenir un des modes de résolution du
conflit dans notre pays et ça c'est
extrêmement grave parce que ça veut dire
qu'il ya une défiance de plus en plus
grande
alors défiance et impuissance de l'état
est aidée de ses acteurs pour enrayer le
phénomène bienvenue sur ce plateau force
à marfa niçois merci d'être là je le
disais vous êtes policier syndicaliste
secrétaire départemental adjoint d'unité
sgp police fo
je vais vous montrer un reportage plus
large sur ce qui s'est passé à champigny
ce qui s'est passé à herblay et vous
allez nous dire ce que vous vivez sur
ses tirs de mortiers d'artifice très
précisément vous vous souhaitez qu'on
arrête
est ce que c'est possible alors je
voudrais pas qu'on fasse vraiment un
focus uniquement sur le feu d'artifice
parce que sur l'arrivée des barres de
fer et des barres de fer et des boules
de pétanque y avait des billes en plomb
alors je veux bien que ce darmanin
interdisent toutes les armes par
destination de l'iran interdisent la
commercialisation des boules de pétanque
ça va faire ça va faire mal sur sur
marseille s'ils peuvent plus acheter des
boules de pétanque
est-ce qu'on va interdire les barres de
fer est ce qu'on va interdire tous les
objets lancés sur les prix de l'or la
bonne réponse pour d'autant plus qu'on
sait très bien qu'avec le darknet eh
bien je pense que si on interdit la
vente sur les grands sites marchands
français on arrivera toujours à trouver
des mortiers d'artifices pourquoi on
voit de plus en plus
ce genre de feu de feu d'artifice de
mortier comme ça on a l'impression que
sur internet certains jeunes font une
sorte de compétition pour savoir qui
réussira le plus à l'utiliser contre tel
ou tel alors commissariat monsieur black
ops qui disait que ça faisait déjà
quasiment quinze ans que ce projectile
était utilisé à l'égard des forces de
l'anp c'était quand même très marginale
avant on était encore jusqu'à ya 5 6 ans
sur des projectiles dit classique alors
mal je suis désolé de dire qu'on
n'utilise des projectiles classique sur
les policiers mais on était plus sûr des
jets de pierres on était plus sûr des
jets de bouteilles on était plus sur du
matériel de comme ça qu'on trouvait sur
la république ils ont aussi découvert il
ya tout le monde se met à la pointe de
du modernisme ils ont trouvé ces engins
incendiaires pyrotechnique qui comme l'a
dit très bien
thibault de montbrial sont très
dangereux sont brûlants explosif et que
la volonté cette faire mal sinon on
utiliserait de vieux moyen - enfin -
blessant or le feu d'artifice c'est
pratique on peut le tirer de loin donc
on n'est pas en contact direct avec le
policier ou le pompier ou le
représentant de l'état que l'on vise
c'est aussi un peu une cour dise parce
qu'on s'éloigne le plus possible de la
victime pour essayer de l'atteindre mais
c'est pour ça que focaliser sur la coupe
et la filière vin coupé le moyen de
s'approvisionner en tout cas en mortier
non moi je veux pas faire de publicité
pour les ouvrages mais il faut en effet
osé pour les autorise à la racine du mal
eh ben on y va justement on va plonger
dans ce débat sur sur ses attaquants on
le dit ultraviolente vous l'avez dit
elles sont loin d'être nouvelle elles
sont anciennes mais elles sont dans leur
violence beaucoup plus intense regardons
cela avec clément méric
les images sont impressionnantes et le
message envoyé aux policiers glaçant ce
phénomène n'est pas nouveau
ce commissariat de champigny sur marne a
été attaqué à plusieurs reprises depuis
2011 est cette nuit les commissariat de
champigny et choisy-le-roi ont été visés
par des tirs de mortier selon la police
en 2003 quand un poste de police et
incendié au cocktail molotov à pau
nicolas sarkozy réaffirme l'autorité de
la république
un refrain repris depuis par tous les
gouvernements
l'état n'a pas l'intention de céder et
chaque fois qu'il ya un problème je
ferai comme cela ce n'est pas nous qui
reculeront parce que si on recule c'est
la démocratie qui recule à deux zones de
droit qui a un est à présent exercer son
autorité c'est l'état et la république
qui sont pris pour cible ou serons
intraitables
je suis venu dire à tous ceux qui
essayent de tester la république in
europa si les discours se ressemblent
les attaques elles sont plus violente et
plus fréquentes que par le passé ces
images amateurs n'ont pas fait la une
des journaux
elle remonte au mois de juillet 2019 une
antenne de crs visés par des mortiers
d'artifices à saint denis depuis le
début de l'année le figaro a recensé au
moins neuf attaques de commissariats
voitures incendiées policiers agressés
poste de police près possible en 2018
plus de 6000 policiers ont été blessés
alors qu'ils étaient en mission
un chiffre en hausse de 16% sur un an on
attendait politique à ce qui est des
choses concrètes qu'il soit fait en
terme justement de protection mais aussi
de politique pénale
les syndicats espèrent obtenir une
réponse après demain ils seront reçus à
l'elysée par emmanuel macron
hossam hassan et vous vous la voyez
monter vous cette violence ils viennent
pour tuer c'est ce que disent les les
policiers de champigny oui très
clairement on a changé vraiment de
paradigme je dirais déjà qu'avec 2016 et
et viry châtillon où on a voulu brûler
vif à des policiers dans les voitures
qui n'étaient pas en opération de police
forte sur des délinquants il était là en
surveillance d'une vidéo protection
on a vu qu'il y avait maintenant la
volonté vraiment de nuire de nuire mais
gravement a prévenu on a eu les la loi
elle conneries ou l'appareil
on est passé sur des actes dans les
manifestations qu'on ne trouvait pas
avant des actes de plus en plus grave on
a vu des voitures se faire se faire
brûler lors de manifestations qui est en
guerre contre à la pince et bien le
problème c'est qu'on n'est plus
uniquement sur les caïds les caïds ou
les certains délinquants de sites et ça
c'était les années 90 où on attaquait
les commissaires comme à trappes dans
mon département ou hoon attaqué avec une
voiture bélier les portes des
commissariats
ensuite on a eu des violences très
graves pendant les manifestations
sociales donc par des manifestants donc
on a maintenant tout une succession en
fête de famille de d'humains qui se met
à attaquer la police et même des
citoyens lambda puisque quand on arrive
à interpeller des auteurs de violences
sur les policiers
on a pas on a des profils très
différentes on a nous n'allons vraiment
l'impression que les digues ont sauté et
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
eh bien il n'y a plus eu bien sûr il ya
plus respect de l'autorité et la police
et nous on peut avoir du monsieur tout
le monde fasse à nouveau en garde à vue
où je suis officier de police judiciaire
j'ai des profils très différents sur des
attaques envers les forces de l'ordre ça
ressemble à une forme d'ensauvagement de
la société un climat dans la société go
bernalicis qui fait que la la
l'intensité de la violence augmente dans
ces camps les profils sont il a juste
pas vrai enfin j'ai messieurs viennent
nous dire que déjà dans les années 90 il
y avait des voitures béliers qu'ils font
c'est un commissariat alors seco de
nouveaux 1981 il ya 30 ans quand même
hein donc peut-être que ça prend
d'autres formes peut-être qu'on avait
moins accès aux feux d'artifice avec moi
ton n'y a plus accès mais j'ai pas
l'impression que là bas un climat
particulier étant d une chose même la
statistique globale dans ce pays c'est
que les violences contrairement à ce qui
était dit tout à l'heure les violences
les agressions physiques dans la rue
sont en baisse depuis les 30 dernières
années et c'est tant mieux
c'est une bonne nouvelle après est ce
qu'il y ait encore des violences et ce
qui est encore des comportements m
cible bien sûr bien sûr est ce qu'il ya
un climat qui qui se désagrège dans
certains certains quartiers du pays bien
sûr pourquoi s'était dit tout à l'heure
par le collègue gouffier chat je suis à
200% d'accord est ce qu'il a dit il ya
un recul de la république au sens global
il ya plus de service public qui a plus
de boulot il ya plus de bureaux de poste
il n'y a plus et c'est excellent mais
vous entendrez aussi s'étant déjà blessé
qu'il vous dise on n'en peut plus de
mais bien sûr qu'ils ont des grilles cus
de la république en permanence alors que
je l'avais des des jeunes qui on fonde
sur une peur de rien pour sage et
confortent leur vous me parlez de plutôt
d' excuses personne ne parle de culture
la république a failli mais ça n'excuse
rien on pose un constat
moi je n'excuse rien je dis juste
comment on fait pour se projeter pour
régler la situation
attention à pas mêler des choses qui
n'ont rien à voir vous pouvez pas mêler
ce qui se passe dans une manifestation
avec ce qui s'est passé à champigny sur
marne
pas plus que vous pouvez mettre dans le
même sac les deux policiers de pgi en
civil qui étaient en planque compte des
gens qui font de la criminalité
organisée
ça naît ça n'a rien à voir il faut les
traiter d'ailleurs différemment c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il ya des services
de police différent dans ce pays entre
la sécurité publique entre la police
judiciaire entre le maintien de l'ordre
à chaque métier ses responsabilités ses
objectifs opérationnels et c'est tant
mieux comme ça parce que c'est la
meilleure réponse qu'on peut alors des
bois de montbrial j'aimerais avoir votre
sentiment parce qu'on vend ensuite
essayer de voir ce qu'on peut apporter
comme comme solution mais sur sur ce
climat gouvernance d attention à ne pas
tout mélanger
c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas dans la
statistique là on n'est plus dans
l'émotion d'abord la statistique
contrairement à ce qui dit elle montre
une augmentation des faits les plus
violents mais je ne rentre même pas dans
un débat statistiques ce qu'on constate
et là je suis vraiment pas et là je suis
je suis vraiment je pense qu'il ya une
vraie erreur d'analysé un déni il m'a
pas de là chacun appelle ça comme on
veut c'est que évidemment que on peut
pas traiter de la même façon des
violences graves lors d'une
manifestation et la tentative
d'assassinât contre les deux officiers
de pj harvey par contre il ya un fil
conducteur c'est que dans différents
champs social qui n'ont rien à voir les
uns avec les autres
les gens vont agresser les boules un
passage à l'aller il ya eu un passage à
l'acte qui est je le maintiens est de
plus en plus récurrents donc une
augmentation des actes et une
intensification
des actes donc venir vous prenez alors
là c'est on parle de contre les
policiers mais sur la violence dans le
pays
vous prenez les villes moyennes cet été
vous prenez vous prenez rennes vous
prenez nantes vous prenez grenoble vous
prenez lyon vous prenez bordeaux vous
parlez comme je lé fais je le raconte
dans mon livre au procureur au préfet au
patron des services de police aux
patrons des services de gendarmerie
tout le monde y en a qui sont de droite
y en a qui sont de gauche à titre
personnel de dix gèrent chacun à sa
conviction de citoyens mais la
conviction professionnels de tous ces
gens c'est ce constat d'une
intensification et d'une fragmentation
de notre société et de l'utilisation de
la violence comme mode de résolution du
conflit
donc après on peut dire que il fallait
traiter les choses qu'il faut il faut
vous savez c'est le pegi dit il faut
dire ce que l'on voit mais d'abord il
faut voir ce qu'on le voit donc les gens
qui pour des raisons politiques disent
que ça n'existe pas moi je suis pas
inquiet parce qu'à un moment vous savez
les gens du bon sens maison des jeux
pour voir sur le diagnostic c'est plus
grave qu'avant je me suis toujours sur
les comparaisons par rapport à avant
j'aurais la société telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui et qu'elle est elle
aujourd'hui
mais on constate qu'il y à des attaques
des agressions envers nos forces de
l'ordre une espèce de banalisation
qu'effectivement existe ce que c'était
bien c'était pas la même société
en 1981 qu'aujourd'hui et d'autres
violences il y avait un autre contexte
social il y avait une autre société
on connaît d'autre réalité aujourd'hui
la réalité celle qu'il faut regarder
c'est les violences qui sont faites
c'est effectivement des personnes qui
viennent dans différentes mais les
occasions pour tous vous entendez les
pas les siennes hier ya une forme de
sentiment d'impunité
on a on l'entendait avant le 7 avril
effectivement il faut le traiter il a
raison sur on va dire que le traitement
pénal
derrière mais naïve mais on est au bout
quand sur le sujet banlieue on est au
bout on traite les conséquences d'un tas
de des équipes souvent dans nos
quartiers moi je suis désolé de voir
qu'il ne reste plus que deux services
publics
vous resterez si la police et des
policiers qui sont bien soignés
s'appelle commises je le connais
largement connaît mais par exemple
acheter il faut un deuxième commissariat
champigny on a renforcé les effectifs de
25 effectifs supplémentaires sur
champignons mais c'était pas assez par
rapport au retard et pas la nuit
il faut donc pour vous c'est une
question de moyens il ya une question de
moyens le deuxième service public qui
est souvent bien seul il faut pas
l'oublier c'est l'éducation nationale où
là aussi on se retrouve avec des écoles
seuls certains quartiers ce que vous
prendrez négatives dans des quartiers où
toutes les difficultés sociales
effectivement s'accumulent demanderez un
très bon on demanderait on demanderait à
notre police et un autre éducation
nationale de régler toutes les
difficultés serre c'est ça aussi ça va
qu'on voit pas forcément de mettre
d'accord de l'état à qui on demanderait
certains policiers je le ressens dans à
qui on demanderait de régler tous les
problèmes du quartier et ça ce n'est
plus possible aujourd'hui
les constables vous faites les uns les
autres on n'est pas d'accord sur tout
mais sur le fait qu' il ya ya ya ya des
vraies lacunes notamment dans le rôle de
l'état on est d'accord moi moi ce que je
propose dans le livre il ya des constats
et des solutions
je pense qu'il faut que je pense je
pensais pas que l'état s'est pas connu
de retard c'est notamment l'état et je
pense mais mais restons sur l'état mais
vous avez parlé de l'étape c'est toute
la société vous avez raison mais en
l'occurrence je vous avais parlé de
l'état parlera du reste de la société
après je pense que il faut qu il est
urgentissime parce que moi je suis très
inquiet pour la suite et à court terme
mais il est urgentissime de repenser
l'utilisation des priorités de l'état et
notamment budgétaires vous avez le
budget régalien qui sont à peu près à 3%
et les budgets sociaux à 60
si ça avait du marché depuis quarante
ans ça se saurait on a aujourd'hui un
pays qui perd fracturait qui est au bord
de l'éclatement sur différents fronts
donc c'est l'équivalent donc c'est la
preuve que celui des de la police et du
bd d'ajuster le budget de la police et
du budget de la justice et je donne une
indication parce que là c'est que quand
monsieur castaner me dis je raconte nos
entretiens dans le livre pas dans le
détail parce que je viole pas les
secrets mais quand il me dit ne vous
inquiétez pas
cette année on a le budget du ministère
blatter le plus élevé de qu'on n'a
jamais eue c'est du titre 2 c'est à dire
que le titre 2 c'est le titre sur des
dépenses de personnel
mais le titre sur les dépenses
d'équipements et de moyens et
fonctionnement ça ne fait qu ont les
moyens sur les moyens que bcns voit le
drame à barcelone à dreux technique sur
le budget j'aurais tellement de moyens
de fonctionnement et bien sûr c'est ce
que vous réclamez bien équipé je voulais
quand même vous poser la question sur
sur cette ultra violence comment vous
l'expliquez on dit beaucoup que le
confinement a peut avoir un effet
notamment sur la question du trafic de
drogue que ça peut assécher le marché
que ça a rendu nerveux dévoila des
quartiers entiers qui pourrait expliquer
ces tensions c'est vrai c'est faux non
non ça c'est faux sur le trafic de
stupéfiants pendant le confinement il y
avait d'autres méthodes de livraison que
de faire déplacer le client on a on a
constaté tous les services qui enquêtent
ont constaté qu'il y avait des systèmes
de livraison du coup au domicile des
consommateurs ou des acheteurs pour
éviter que ces acheteurs ne soit bloqué
dans la dans l'approvisionnement donc ce
nom il faut
moi je verrai comment vous l'expliquez
vous dijon l'été dernier des conserves
les chantiers nice un point c'est pas
forcément toujours défendues depuis
toujours je voudrais qu'on sorte
l'histoire de violence ne pas la laisser
pas la contourner au quartier parce que
la tentation c'est tout jamais de
revenir sur les jeunes des cités on a on
a vu tout en haut de l'été que nous
avions décollaient qui ont été
grièvement blessés ou qui sont
décédé sur par exemple des refus
d'obtempérer qui n'avaient pas lieu dans
les cités qui avait lieu dans des villes
normal au moment où autres donc là
obtempéré à quoi enfin contre eux de
gérer par des véhicules et qu'ils et
traînait des policiers ou des gendarmes
on l'a vu dans le lot et garonne dont on
est là on n'était vraiment pas dans un
quartier dans un quartier sensible
c'est pour ça que le profil de
l'agresseur nanterre qu'aujourd'hui le
haut il ya encore quinze vingt ans moi
ça fait 23 ans que ces officiers de
police ça fait vingt trois ans sur la
police et 15 ans que l'officier de
police judiciaire
il ya encore vingt ans quand on
attaquait des policiers c'était pour se
défendre parce qu'on venait de braquer
une banque
c'était des personnes qui étaient en
fuite c'était des fugitifs ou c'étaient
des gens qui venaient faire un grave
crime aujourd'hui pour échapper un délit
routier ou pour échapper un délit du
quotidien on est capable de faire subir
aux forces de l'ordre
les mêmes blessures ou mort que ce que
des grands bandits faisait subir ya il
ya quinze ans c'est fort c'est clair
j'ai une anecdote à vous raconter c'est
tout ça va dans le sens de ce que je
disais tout à l'heure mais l'autre jour
un ami qui est officier de gendarmerie
assiste alors qu'il rentre chez lui en
civil à une bagarre entre automobilistes
dans les hauts-de-seine
c'est vous dire que et dans une dans une
partie plutôt cossue des hauts-de-seine
donc on n'est pas sur les sujets
problématiques site etc
il sort de la voiture et il dit
messieurs calmez-vous etc et par
habitude ils disent je suis gendarme
calmez vous et que croyez vous qu'il
arriva les deux s'unissent contre lui et
le mec se fait péter la gueule juste
parce qu'il a dit qu'il était genre
voilà ça illustre mieux qu'un long
discours
une évolution qui fait que l'hypothèse
de la violence contre celui qui dit
qu'il est policier ou gendarme
aujourd'hui elle ne dérange plus
personne juste le sur les refus
d'obtempérer aujourd'hui c'est un acte
en moyenne toutes les demi heures c'est
à dire un policier ou un gendarme
renversé par une voiture toutes les demi
heures c'est vrai qu'on avait sur les
solutions gaubert na li 6 vous avez sans
doute et vous serez pas d'accord sur un
peu plus que ce post frédéric péchenard
allez-y puis je n'en mets l'enfer un peu
la part des choses de ce que
l'augmentation de la violence elle et
elle n'est pas juste envers les
policiers
et aussi une augmentation des violences
contre les manifestants manifestations
dans les quartiers populaires de ce
qu'on appelle communément les bavures et
je crois qu à champigny sur marne ce
n'est pas complètement étranger à
ce qui s'est passé quelques jours avant
ou un jeune a été semble-t-il à jean
sérien peut-être lé enquête le dira
machin que ça fait renverser à priori
par un véhicule de police jean st je
suis pas sur place mais c'est ce que ray
motiver une partie des gens qui se sont
attaqués au commissariat et si c'est
faux ces intentions du malheureux qu'ils
se soient attaqués au commissariat en
question j'avais vu déjà il ya trois
quatre ans avant le confinement j'ai vu
un même cas de figure ici en région
parisienne aussi où elle pourrait
pourtant c'est un problème présent oui
c'est un problème on est en train quand
je vois le préfet l'allemand qui dit à
deux camps m'attendais c'est pas ça
l'objectif politique l'objectif
politique c'est pas dire il ya deux
camps et en a un qui va gagner c'est
celui de la police nationale contre le
reste le l'objectif c'est que le niveau
de violence diminuent dans la société
alors tout le monde c'est ça l'objectif
politique
moi je il pourrait donc les armes encore
plus lourde encore plus de l bd coq et
des yeux qui qu'il soit crevé encore
davantage ce n'est pas la religion je
voudrais vous soumettre quelques
propositions qui sont dans le débat
public depuis quelques jours certaines
correspondent à la réponse pénale que
vous attendez d'autres correspondent à
la question des armes
frédéric péchenard des clairement qu'il
faut se poser la question de la légitime
défense déposé des policiers et que les
policiers doivent riposter jankovic à la
première question qui se pose je vous
donne le temps de répondre c'est quelle
riche bost on doit réfléchir sur la
riposte immédiate on voit bien que les
policiers n'ont pas riposté dans né dans
ce cas ni dans un autre ils sont soumis
à tout un tas de contraintes juridiques
administratives qui font qu'à aucun
moment ces policiers ont sorti leurs
armes
oui mieux mais tant mieux le jeu je
pense qu'on a des forces de police aussi
qui sont particulièrement fort mais qui
ont eu les bons réflexes
l'autre soir à champigny tant que naisse
pied et ben affleck non mais ce qui se
serait passé après s'il avait risque pas
ces jeux
je ne sais pas de toute façon c'était
4-2
donc on est moins d'accord mais
aujourd'hui en fait l'état de droit
entre aujourd'hui il doit se manifester
par des policiers qui doivent reculer ce
s'enfermer dans un sas de leur
commissariat pour éviter d'être tué ou
blessé alors solide et de monsieur
péchenard
c'est sous les renforts d'effets sur le
scénariste will et renforce sa chérie
grm c'est encore la nuit dans la police
nationale nous c'est une fausse bonne
idée
les syndicats n ont pas les pas du tout
ça parce que sur champigny mois de ce
qu'on va remonter notamment beaucoup de
mineurs par exemple oui mais non mais la
demi-heure majeure non mélangés je suis
désolé mais j'imagine c'est une bonne
idée présent pour la rive je suis en
train c'est que le millefeuille
législatif entre le code de sécurité
intérieure le code de procédure pénale
qui donne la possibilité aux policiers
de se défendre
existe déjà donc je sais que quand il ya
un fait divers on a toujours tendance à
le législateur se dit enfin où le
gouvernant politique je garde un si
jeune je crée une nouvelle loi en plus
un porte monnaie
comme ça j'aurai une loi dupont durand
expliquez nous donc là ce qui existe pas
l'impression d'aller choix il me devient
elle existe de taille cette riposte
proportionnelle une riposte qui doit
être nécessaire une réponse une riposte
qui doit être simultané par rapport à
l'atteinte grave sur le sur le policier
ou sur le gendarme donc là en
l'occurrence là où peut parfois se poser
le problème c'est la proportionnalité
parce qu'aujourd'hui nos collègues ils
sont une idée pourquoi ils sont ils
étaient in il est parce que par exemple
s'ils sont attaqués par 3-1 a dit un
policier attaqué par trois individus
avec des barres de fer
il va se il va se poser la question
est-ce que je vais utiliser une arme
létale pour me défendre contre trois
individus 500 kg et si je prends les
trois coups de barre de fer
je vais avoir un traumatisme crânien et
je peux et je peut en mourir donc les
policiers ont tendance maintenant à ne
plus vouloir utiliser leurs armes à
vouloir fuir on a beaucoup de koné qui
sont obligés de prendre parfois la fuite
s'est pas c'est pas plaisant de vous le
dire sur un plateau c'est pour ça que
nous la question qu'on pose aujourd'hui
c'est comment on peut assurer la
sécurité des français
quand nous mêmes on se sent en dans une
telle insécurité que parfois on est
obligé de prendre la fuite
ses bonnes ondes real est une auto
censure des policiers par rapport à la
loi
c'est la société qui font d'eux c'est
vraiment un sujet que je connais bien et
que j'enseigne dans les écoles de police
et de gendarmerie
1 il ya évidemment une énorme
autocensuré il ya chaque année et chaque
mois chaque semaine est presque chaque
jour aujourd'hui des situations où
l'état de légitime défense existe
juridiquement et où les policiers ne
font pas usage de leur as il ya deux
manières de voir les choses
dans l'immense majorité des cas on peut
dire exactement ce qu'on vient
d'entendre c'est à dire tant mieux et
c'est après on peut essayer d'aller un
peu plus loin
moi ce que j'entends ces deux élus de la
république si on en est composé et qui
viennent d'exprimer un lâche soulagement
pourquoi parce qu'on dit ouh là là tant
mieux tant mieux il s'est rien passé on
rend hommage
ils ont été remarqués à abidjan etc le
problème c'est que quand des policiers
se font tuer sa gêne beaucoup moins
parce que l'on donne une médaille on
fait une cérémonie ont fait un beau
discours et on passe à la suite alors
que quand c'est les policiers qui se
défendent et qui défendent en de cette
façon la république dont il porte
l'uniforme dans le cadre de la loi je
parle d'eux des gens qui râlent
évidemment des gens qui respectent la
loi
à ce moment-là ça déclenche tout un tas
de troubles parce que c'est exploiter
politiquement et le problème c'est que
c'est là la paille dans l'oeil
c'est que ce faisant on ne se rend pas
compte que l'autorité de l'état et le
retour à tout sujet dont on parlait tout
à l'heure c'est à dire oui mais l'état
dans les quartiers l'enseignement et
l'autorité de l'état a tellement reculé
que aujourd'hui les gens qui agressent
les policiers ils sont surpris quand
quelqu'un se défend ils sont surpris en
valois oise il n'a pas le droit et où
donc est on est on est en train dont on
est qu par dessus tête et comme je pense
qu'il est inéluctable au rythme où ça va
que nous ayons dans les landes dans les
semaines ou dans les mois mais avant la
mort avant 2022 une situation où on va
se réveiller un matin en apprenant qu'il
ya eu cinq ou six morts par un échange
respectifs de coups de feu entre des
policiers et je ne sais pas je ne sais
plus si ce sera des gens de sites et
d'un islamiste ou autre et bien à ce
moment là tout le monde ce sera la
gueule de bois tout le monde et on dira
comment est-ce qu'on en est arrivé là
mais on y est déjà là alors je voudrais
je voudrais juste terminer ce débat par
un dernier tour de table sur la question
de la réponse pénale les interpellations
marine le pen disait ce matin pas assez
d'interpellations les paies de lait
peine une fois ce qui irait
personnellement interpellé elles sont
pas exécutées est ce qu'il ya un
problème de réponse pénale du côté de la
justice
danser dans ces questions là oui mais
pas celui là c'est pas ça le problème il
ya jamais eu autant de personnes
interpellées et que des personnes soient
relâchés parce que la procédure a été
mal faite et que la personne en cause
n'est pas n'a pas être mis en cause j'ai
envie de vous dire ça c'est le principe
d'un état de droit et des principes de
sûreté quoi et tant mieux si c'est le
cas puisque les policiers agissent sous
l'autorité des magistrats et c'est très
bien comme ça je pense que l'autorité
des magistrats justement elle n'est pas
assez visible et pas assez présente
auprès des policiers sas études et
pourquoi parce qu'on a deux fois moins
de magistrats par habitant par rapport à
l'allemagne
enfin je veux dire voilà moi je suis
france insoumise et je vous dis je veux
deux fois plus de magistrats dans ce
pays voilà et si vous voulez ça eh ben
il faut le budget en conséquence
et derrière il y aura pas de difficulté
à vous dire que les délais de traitement
des jugements iront deux fois plus vite
si vous avez de la place de magistrats
alors je vais pas faire le catalogue
revendicatif de mon organisation
syndicat unité sgp police qui est la
première organisation de france
mais nous on a toujours réclamé que pour
traiter des procédures ou des policiers
et bien ont été victimes de violences
graves voire policiers et personnes
chargées de service public on pourrait
rajouter les élus haut pour y rajouter
voilà les pompiers qu'il y ait une
juridiction spécialisée qui un ski
instruisez qui juge ces affaires aussi
bien d'ailleurs que les affaires où des
policiers sont soupçonnés d'avoir commis
des violences illégitimes sur l'individu
dans un moment où on arrête les jeux et
les choses spécialisés les jurys mais
vous avez encore des tribunaux
d'exception vous avez encore le tribunal
des affaires sociales oui il existe
encore il existe encore une cour
d'assises qui juge les faits de
terrorisme
il existe encore des juridictions des
juridictions spéciales donc on pourrait
très bien estimé aujourd'hui que vu la
gravité des faits et justement pour pas
à charge et à décharge pour traiter les
affaires où les policiers sont mises en
cause et où les policiers sont victimes
parce qu'il faut il faut quand même que
le magistrat qui juge ne juge
sereinement et avec une connaissance
fine
aujourd'hui quand on est attaqué les
forces de police au nez juges et autres
un vol à l'étalagé
entre une dégradation de l'écrit en deux
doses at il un collectionneur
vous allez rencontrer gérald darmanin
demain c'est bien ça et vous lui ferez
part de jeu du doigt revendications le
président république le président de la
république pardonnez moi merci beaucoup
on va s'arrêter là parce que je voudrais
qu'on garde un tout petit peu de temps
pour votre livre vous vouliez conclure
aujourd'hui parce que nommé par le
troupeau du point
la nuit qui se sont mobilisés ils se
sont lancés un collectif s'appelle
option nuit et moi j'aimerais qu'on
puisse les entendre ces gens là parce
qu'ils ont des revendications légitimes
sur les conditions de travail des
policiers la nuit il ya trop peu de
policiers la nuit et on en prévoit de
les faire travailler à rosières année le
mot de la fin revient au goût juste
effectivement un corps en bois il faut
renforcer les moyens la justice mais il
faut au moins quand j'entends les
policiers qui nous disent qu'ils passent
leur temps à courir après les mêmes
personnes qui sont arrêtés et relâchés
ça ce n'est plus possible et notamment
sur le trafic de stups qui pourrit la
vie de nos banlieues et où un moment
c'est à se demander non ya pas besoin de
légaliser non non parce que ça passera
sur le débat merci vous restez avec nous
thibault de montbrial je le disais ça
tapait lauzon l'autorité aux édition de
l'observatoire c'est au fond une analyse
de la crise profonde autorités que
traverse notre pays au fou ce qu'il a
déclenchée à vous lire
c'est cet épisode 1986 manifestations
étudiantes mais les coups c'est qu'ils
regardent évacués de la sorbonne les
derniers étudiants sont pourchassés dans
le quartier latin au coin d'une rue
malik oussékine est violemment prise à
partie par les policiers motocyclistes
et les crs
il va mourir malgré les massages
cardiaques trois policiers auraient roué
de coups le jeune étudiant ce soir le
procureur de la république déclare que
l'autopsié n'a révélé aucune fracture ni
aucune lésion cérébrale le visage de
malik oussékine est tout de même très
sérieusement contusionné
pour le procureur une grave maladie
rénale dont souffre l étudiant pourrait
être plus directement que les coûts
responsable de sa décompression
cardiaque fin de citation reste
l'intervention musclée de ce peloton
voltigeurs motocyclistes en renfort des
crs des équipages de deux policiers sur
des motos tout terrain chargé de
disperser à l'aide de longues matraques
en bois
les derniers manifestants l'inspection
générale des services de la police a
ouvert une enquête mais n'a comme
d'habitude rien révélé au public je puis
des mannequins ou art vous dire que les
forces de police ont fait leurs devoirs
et obéit aux instructions du land était
donné voilà la ferme à l'écossé qui ne
vous en parlais au début de votre livre
ça n'est absolument pas tous les
ouvrages mais dites vous ça peut
permettre de comprendre comment au fond
sur le maintien de l'ordre
on a progressivement jusqu'à récemment
perdu au fond dallas la capacité de
maintenir l'ordre public
le livre fait un audit de tous les
segments de l'autorité en matière de
sécurité après intérieur donc le premier
chapitre c'est sur le maintien de
l'ordre mais il y en a sept sur laquait
et après il ya un certain nombre de
solutions sur malik oussékine ce que je
dit juste c'est que il ya une tétanie
depuis depuis ce jour là sur la façon
dont les autorités appréhende la foule
dans les manifestations donc il faut
évidemment se réjouir de ce que la
france n'est pas connu d'autres morts en
charente
simplement j'ai à dire juste l'attention
sur un point précis c'est que
systématiquement dans l'histoire d'un
cinquième république depuis le milieu
des années 80 lorsqu'il ya eu un
mouvement de protestation avec des
violences à la fin contre un projet de
loi le projet a toujours été non ce qui
permet d'expliquer cette cette crise de
l'autorité que vous souhaitez
réhabiliter restaurer c'est la crise du
maintien de l'ordre
la crise de la justice on en a parlé un
petit peu et vous aller très loin vous
parler de la crise des frontières en
fait vous expliquer clairement qu'ils
aient un lien entre immigration et
délinquance que quand on a mal contrôlé
nos frontières on a fait venir des
migrants qui ont favorisé d'une certaine
façon la délinquance on a fait venir on
a si vous voulez en 40 ans la population
de la france et de l'europe a
complètement changé
donc on a il ya des choses qu'on
n'aurait pas dû laisser faire comme
comme on les a laissé faire parce qu on
a petit à petit abandonné le lait
l'autorité de base sur un certain nombre
de préceptes sur ce qu'on pouvait
tolérer comme mode de vie en france etc
on a laissé le sujet de l'autorité au
front national ce qui est à mon avis une
erreur absolument tragique l'autorité de
la république mon autorité à moi c'est
l'autorité républicaine et moqueries
dans ce livre c'est de dire que le
rétablissement de l'autorité sur un
certain nombre de champs qui sont les
piliers régaliens c'est pour sauver la
république d'ailleurs la première des
mesures celles que je le slogan que je
que je dis partout c'est que la première
des autorités c'est d'appliquer nos lois
donc vous devez d'ailleurs on n'a pas
besoin de lois nouvelles à notre très
peu besoin de nouvelles idées à petit
vous revenez beaucoup sur la question de
l'exécution des lois et des peines
notamment mais sur l'immigration vous
assumez mais sur l'immigration j'assume
au nom de quoi s go
quand vous invitez des gens chez vous
vous choisissez combien de personnes
viennent dîner vous choisissez s'il
reste le dîner le week-end où les
vacances mais vous c'est vous qui
choisissez
et si au bout d'un moment vous dites à
un copain un peu lourd parce qu'il se
séparait de sa copine maintenant tu as
dormi ici dix jours ce serait bien que
tu trouve un logement il va finir par
partir
au nom de quoi est-ce qu'on organiserait
pas notre politique d'immigration sur
manuel da cruz n'a pas parlé des
migrations dans son discours sur le
séparatisme et j'avais pourtant oui
parce que je pense qu'il a eu totalement
raison c'est un discours que je salue
enfin c'est à dire que je l'aimé
beaucoup attendu la démo ont été eux mis
sur des mots et mahut 6 je salue une
influence des gens autour des modèles
macron qui sont sur cette ligne laïque
lucide un jean michel blanquer gérald
darmanin le rhône une aise mais il a
bien fait de pas parler d'immigration
pourquoi parce que c'est le même sujet
global mais c'est pas le même sujet
juridique la loi sur le séparatisme sur
l'islamisme est une c'est une loi contre
l'islamisme politique
par contre l'islamisme politique découle
évidemment de l'immigration le et en ce
sens il est évident qu'il y ait un lien
par contre je ne rejoins absolument pas
le front national par exemple qui a
critiqué le discours présidentiel alors
que vous voyez moi c'est ça que j'aime
pas dans la politique aujourd'hui leur
assemblée nationale mais le
rassemblement national les républicains
qui sont des partis qui sont sur ces
lignes là depuis un moment quand ils ont
un président de la république qui dit ce
que eux-mêmes attendent et ils vous le
disent tous en privé ils vont critiquer
non les français méritent mieux que ça
alors vous vous donnez on voit bien
qu'il ya une volonté politique à
l'oeuvre il faudra quand même voir ce
que ça donne dans l'émoi dans les mois
qui viennent à la fin de votre livre
vous parlez d'un combat culturel aussi
un combat une identité
oui un combat identitaire parce que moi
je pense que je suis très frappé
par le fait que les islamistes par
exemple puisqu'on parle du séparatisme
ils recrutent ils séduisent les jeunes
avec un projet qui repose sur de la
transcendance c'est à dire qu'ils ont
l'oumma la communauté musulmane la
conquête etc
et ils disent quand on s'intéresse au
sujet on voit qu'ils disent les kouffar
c'est à dire nous regardent et s'éteint
c'est un peuple qui n'a plus que de
l'individualisme ya plus de projets
collectifs etc
or nous avons un merveilleux projet
collectif aujourd'hui le vivre ensemble
n'existe plus c'est un slogan vide qui
est utilisé par des gens qui vivent dans
des quartiers où ils se gardent bien de
l'appliquer ce que je voudrais moi c'est
qu'on retrouve un vrai vivre ensemble et
pour ça il faut c'est comme un
psychanalyste il faut commencer par
s'aimer soi-même sans arrogance et très
hâte donc sans arrogance mais sans
faiblesse
qu'est ce que nous sommes nous sommes un
pays aux racines gréco-latine de
tradition judéo-chrétienne et il me
semble qu'il ya quatre grandes valeurs
du jour les valeurs bien moins les
valeurs je les décris dans le livre
c'est le droit de croire ou de ne pas
croire le droit d'aimer qui on veut et
mine de rien il ya des vraies
différences le droit les femmes les
femmes moi je pense beaucoup que ce que
le salut viendra des femmes et pour
finir une gouvernance démocratique est
plutôt bienveillante et ça s'appelle
ozon l'autorité il ya aussi des
solutions et des propositions et
beaucoup d'anecdotes et beaucoup
d'anecdotes c'est vrai c'est aux
éditions de l'observatoire vous restez
avec nous thibault de montbrial c'est
l'heure de la chronique de thomas des
prêts que s'est il passé ces dernières
24 heures au palais bourbon et bientôt
ma vous nous raconter le retour
triomphal d'un survivant du commando
palais bourbon c'est bien ça oui
exactement mais liam jean luc reitzer
c'était le premier député contaminés au
qu'ovide 19
il a fait son retour cet après midi dans
l'hémicycle vous raconte tout ça
la dernière fois qu'il avait mis les
pieds dans cet historique salle des
quatre colonnes la france n'avait même
pas encore été à confiner s'en est
suivie de deux mois et demi
d'hospitalisation à mulhouse dont quatre
semaines dans le coma
jean luc reitzer est ce qu'on peut dire
un presque ressuscité alors son retour
c'était au tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle à l'occasion des questions
au gouvernement où il a été beaucoup
beaucoup applaudi alors après les
applaudissements le député alsacien
avait forcément un message pour tous ses
collègues mais pas qu à vous monsieur le
président à tous les collègues issus de
tous les bords de notre assemblée
j'exprime ma reconnaissance pour leurs
messages de soutien et de sympathie
hommage aussi et surtout à tous les
soignants qui ont sauvé tant de vies et
qui mérite des applaudissements
cher jean luc reitzer quel plaisir de
vous revoir ici aujourd'hui
quel plaisir alors après la séance jean
luc reitzer est venu retrouver les
journalistes dans cette salle des quatre
colonnes et il nous a confié sa première
réaction
vous êtes de retour à l'assemblée et oui
c'est un jour très émouvant très
touchant vous avez vu l'accueil que m'a
réservé le groupe l'est républicain dont
je suis membre qui a été extrêmement
chaleureux avec des applaudissements et
puis vous avez vu tout à l'heure aussi
la réaction de tous les collègues sur
tous les bancs vous revenez de très très
loin un homme seul
c'est ce qu'on me dit depuis plusieurs
mois maintenant 1 depuis que je suis
sorti de l'hôpital que j'ai fait ma
rééducation la convalescence des examens
complémentaires puis ce qui a suivi
eh bien oui on me dit partout se rider
on est content de vous revoir ce qui
fait plaisir
et puis c'est vrai qu'on me dit surtout
les médecins d'ailleurs me disent vous
revenez de loin mais je suis vraiment je
suis plus le même parce quand on a passé
par là comme on dit couramment
on ne peut plus être le même et on voit
les choses différemment
qu'est ce que ça vous fait de ces 2
revient dans cette salle que vous avez
pas vues depuis c'était le monde d'avant
même qu'est ce que ça vous fait de
revenir ici bien écouter
ce qui va déjà frappé c'est quand on m'a
dit quand je me suis réveillé du coma
qu'on m'a dit parce que je voulais
rentrer chez moi naturellement
alors on me disait mme sera isère c'est
pas la peine et a personne dans les rues
tout est fermé je les passais tel
confinement
oui je n'ai pas cru je les ai pas cru je
me suis dit ça pour me calmer et donc
c'est vrai que quand on retrouve des
locaux et ça fait quand même trente deux
ans que je suis député
donc quand on retrouve ces locaux qui
sont familiers bah j'avais un moment le
sentiment que je les reverrai plus
jamais voilà meriem vous voyez jean luc
reitzer est bien de retour à l'assemblée
mais comble de la situation il fait son
retour dans l'hémicycle le jour où
l'assemblée adopte de nouvelles mesures
sanitaires pour lutter contre le cornet
virus merci thomas on va ouvrir la page
décryptage de cette émission à présent
une page un peu particulière parce qu'on
va parler d'un anniversaire le nôtre et
on va parler des commissions d'enquêté
parlementaires fait partie bonsoir andré
malet me soit merci d'être avec nous les
téléspectateurs très fidèles dès le cp
vous connaissent bien puisque vous avez
présidé c'était en 2006 la commission d'
enquête parlementaire sur les
dysfonctionnements de la justice dans l'
affaire d'outreau c'est un grand moment
pour vous on va y revenir
vous êtes aujourd'hui sénateur
socialiste de l'isère et bonsoir
stéphane haumant merci d'être là
le réalisateur et vous avez réalisé le
documentaire exceptionnel que vous allez
pouvoir voir demain soir à 21h dans le
cadre de cette grande soirée des 20 ans
des chaînes parlementaires documentaire
qui fait par ailleurs la une de télé obs
cette semaine et qui raconte les
coulisses de ces grandes commission
denquête vous en avez choisi 4 si je ne
dis pas de bêtises avec toutes les
coulisses et tous les grands acteurs
dont andré vallini est qu'ils ont faits
qui ont fait ces moments d'histoire va
tout de suite voir un premier extrait
2006 je le disais pour la première fois
une commission d' enquête parlementaire
ouvre ses portes aux caméras et tout est
filmé en direct regarder le problème de
la justice le problème du fonctionnement
des institutions
c'est l'impression que tout se décide
justement à huis clos
justement en coulisses justement entre
soi et une commission parlementaire plus
elle est publique
plus elle est efficace ce qui était le
déclic c est l audition d acquitter le
dit
janvier je crois et avant de venir il
m'avait fait savoir il avait écrit un
courrier me disant que si leurs
auditions étaient à huis clos il ne
viendrait pas donc j'ai montré ce
courrier à mes collègues
donc on s'est dit qu'on avait du mal
compte tenu de ce qu'avait subi ces
personnes on avait du mal à refuser
cette demande en tout cas c'était une
façon pour elles ces personnes de
pouvoir s'exprimer devant l'ensemble du
peuple français et cette publicité
constitué dans leur esprit une sorte de
réparation il était contre philippe
houillon la diffusion en direct la fallu
le convaincre
il a fallu le convaincre lui bien sûr et
puis tous les membres de la commission
d'enquêté parlementaire qui craignaient
que l'ouverture à la télévision de nos
travaux suscitent du voyeurisme sur une
affaire sordide ceux qui maintenant ce
qui m'a aidé et justement c'est que les
acquittés eux mêmes parce que la
polémique avait avait prospéré dans la
presse entre moi et le reste de la
commission les a quittés en fait savoir
et on fait savoir la commission qu'il
souhaitait justement être auditionnée en
public les caméras il ya eu des moments
d'émotion des moments d'histoire on se
souvient de la prise de parole et d
acquitter on se souvient évidemment du
juge d'instruction fabrice burgaud à
l'origine de ce naufrage judiciaire
il y avait quand même je crois une
petite possibilité pour vous interrompre
les débats en direct c'est ça on m'a
raconté ça il y avait un léger décalage
entre ce qui se passait devant la
commission et la diffusion des images
au cas où il y un dérapage ou cas où des
noms propres soient cités qu'ils ne
devaient pas l'être au cas où l'on parle
de choses trop sordide je disais nation
que c'était une infraction dis donc il y
avait je crois une minutes de décalage
qui permettait à la régie ici de la
chaîne parlementaire d'interrompre la
diffusion est ce que c'est le moment le
plus le plus fort de votre carrière
politique
oui oui oui sans aucun doute c'est un
moment très fort c'est un moment très
fort pour toute l'assemblée nationale
parce que pour une fois si j'ose dire
les parlementaires donnait une bonne
image du travail parlementaire ont
travaillé la gauche et la droite main
dans la main
et on s'intéressait à une affaire
judiciaire qui avait touché des français
ordinaires et le mot ordinaire n'est pas
péjoratif dans ma bouche
cette affaire avait bousculé et plus que
ça avait explosé la vie de plusieurs
dizaines de personnes dans une petite
ville de province alors les gens aiment
beaucoup les faits divers mais il était
aussi totalement bouleversé à l'idée que
ça pousse ça aurait pu leur arriver à
s'identifier
oui tout justement on va les entendre
les acquittés je vous donne la parole
dans un instant stéphane haumant comment
avez vous travaillé d'ailleurs pour
choisir parmi ces centaines d'heures
d'archivés deuxième extrait ce sont ces
a quitté la con on va vous faire écouter
donc me détention provisoire jeudi d'un
match m6 et cosmo l'eau si ça prend la
fin de ma vie mais attendez ça et ça m'a
fait ça m'affecter quand même compris
qui était la prison donc là ça a été les
pleurs j'ai dit non on ne me fait pas on
ne fait surtout pas ça c'est pas
possible je ne pouvais pas m'en faire et
comme ça que j'ai rien fait je sais vous
faut pas les écouter mon badge la
personne qui a répondu ça a été de goût
les menottes dans le dos et embarquer
directement que je savais pas où
j'allais très incarcéré coupe et arrive
à la fin de l'entretien des gens ça a
duré dix minutes l'entretien de jeu pas
compris ce que jean ut c'est rapide je
trouve pas envoyer les gens en prison
dix minutes c'est court comme c'étaient
des moments de vraie vie de vraies
souffrances de vraies grandes
conséquences importantes dans la vie de
chacun qui était exprimée de manière
très digne la plupart du temps par les
personnalités et ça vous prenez à la
gorge c'est la violence de l'injustice
qui sautent aussi au visage de tous les
français qui regardent ça on dirait que
stéphane haumant comment vous avez
travaillé il ya une dramaturgie aussi
qui s'est écrite sous nos yeux à écouter
s'est acquitté les dramaturgies entre
les quatre déjà commission denquête qui
font évoluer comme l'exercice
effectivement là c'est quand même une
sorte de moment de grâce parce que au
delà des aspects techniques
il ya quand même des sortes de
confession humaine enfants tout cas où
avec des gens qui ont été broyés et qui
pour la première fois eu l'occasion de
parler il se trouve qu'ils ont
l'occasion dans la vérité devant
l'assemblée nationale ce qui est quand
même pour assez extraordinaire et qui va
avoir un impact incroyable sur les
spectateurs
il ya des personnages aussi dans cette
commission denquête on parle des
acquittés
il ya aussi le juge burgaud les avocats
les avocats un certain eric
dupond-moretti notamment les bacs le jus
ce qui est étonnant ce qui m'a surpris
c'est que vanille ou le confinement il a
demandé en fait à ce que ce soit public
moi j'étais persuadé qu'il aurait voulu
que ce soir à huis clos burgaud le juge
burgaud est en fait le juge burgaud
burgaud aussi à souhaiter pourra
s'exprimer quand on le voit et dallaire
écrasée par le poids de sa faute et et
des caméras et des flashs qui crépitent
il a été courageux effectivement pas ce
que je lui demandais mois quelques jours
avant l'audition s'il souhaitait le huis
clos
il m'a dit non je souhaite être
auditionnée en public devant les caméras
télévision c'était de sa part très
courageux parce que la pression était
énorme sur lui ces auditions déjà
acquittés d'outreau
c'est drôle parce que une commission
enquête ne remplace pas la justice ans
elle n'a même pas le droit d'enquêter
sur des affaires judiciaires en cours
sauf que là elle vient après un fiasco
judiciaire c'est ce que j'allais vous
dire le travail de votre commission
denquête a vraiment c'est un moment
important dans l'histoire contemporaine
de notre justice
par contre moi j'ai assisté un client
dans le cadre de la sphère benalla et là
on avait une enquête parlementaire qui
avait lieu pendant en parallèle de
l'instruction j'ai même dire avec un
plan prenant même un peu d'avancement
pour autant judiciaire qui est toujours
là et là c'est quand même plus
problématique vous êtes obligés de venir
si le sous peine d'amendé vous prêter
serment alors que c'est absolument
et alors on se met d'accord avec le
président de la commission pour pour de
pain pour qu'il les fait objet précis de
la poursuite ne soit pas évoquée mais
parfois c'est quand même un petit peu
compliqué alors vous avez eu la chance
de vous mettre d'accord avec vos
collègues de l'opposition s'est pas
toujours le cas
on va le voir avec ce deuxième extrait
sur la sphère cahuzac alors là les
députés ne jugez pas du mensonge de
cahuzac mais des dysfonctionnements de
l'action du gouvernement qui ont abouti
à ce scandale d'état
regardez dans son rapport final
le socialiste alain claeys estimera
qu'aucun collègues de jérôme cahuzac au
gouvernement n'a commis la moindre faute
le choc laisse ses vrais amis ont
beaucoup de rondeur dans son rapport
dans la façon de questionner et compris
jérôme cahuzac pour que la sphère
surtout ne reste qu'une affaire qu'il a
usé ne pas dire que c'est un exemple de
2,2 commission denquête mais je pense
qu'elle a joué son rôle avec toutes les
imperfections compris les miennes je
l'entends je me dire on a fait un
travail correct
ce n'est pas l'avis des députés
d'opposition qui refusent de cosigner le
rapport
[Musique]
la majorité hélas à une position je
trouve largement partisane en essayant
de d'écraser la faire quoi et en faisant
cela d'ailleurs moi je pense qu'ils
affaiblissent la démocratie voilà la
commission denquête quand elles sont
politiques
le plus souvent elles sont prises au
piège des logiques politiques
oui c'est plus compliqué parce que quand
on est sur la sphère d'outreau plus ou
moins tout le monde était d'accord pour
régler un problème là on se retrouve
dans une histoire de gauche contre
droite avec bah forcément les députés de
gauche qui ont bien peu de protéger ou
quatre palets trop loin dans l'enquêté
des députés droite qui en rajoutent pour
enquiquiner le pouvoir et ça s'est vu
aussi sur benalla c'est un petit peu la
même chose alors benallal assembler
commission denquête parce qu'en gros on
va les députés ma chronique n'avait pas
du tout envie qu'on a eu embêter les
gens de l'elysée donc quand les camps
les commissions enquêtes sont très
politiques
l'exercice a quand même ses limites
quand ces déçus de société c'est vrai
pour le coup ça marche bien dont elles
sont très politiques elles deviennent
politicienne les commission denquête ce
qui n'était pas le cas de la commission
d' enquête sur l' affaire d'outreau on
était soutenu moi j'étais dans
l'opposition à l'époque j'étais
socialiste gouvernement de dominique de
villepin qui était au pouvoir sous la
présence de jacques chirac
les magistrats qui n'était pas très
content de l'existence de cette
commission se sont plaints aux prisons
la république qui a reçu jacques chirac
a reçu le premier prix de la cour de
cassation
c'est monsieur canivez à l'époque le
procureur général près la cour de
cassation monsieur nadal les deux plus
hauts magistrats du pays et jacques
chirac a dit non le parlement fait son
travail il a soutenu notre travail mais
pourquoi on n'y arrive pas comme les
américains ça pose pas de problème au
sénateur républicain d'aller à six côtés
des ministres ou des représentants
d'administrations pourquoi les
parlementaires français ne s'empare pas
de ce pouvoir là tu vois j'ai vu c'est
une explication finalement qui vous
réellement d'explication c'est que celui
payé tellement grand que les ânes façon
les gens ne se connaissent peu ou pas
donc des élus des 2 d2 opposant fin des
deux bouts du pays ne se connaissent pas
quand il intervient quand ils
interrogent des
d'affaires etc ne les connaissent pas
personnellement en france c'est beaucoup
plus petits tout le monde se connaît et
c'est vrai que les membres des
commissions d enquête seront peut-être
demain dans dogan
oui ils sont du même parti travailler
ensemble et donc c'est peut-être plus
compliqué d'être impertinent et les
choses comme ça oui j'ajoute cette
analyse qui est très intéressante le
fait que sous la vème république le
parlement est soumis aux goûts le
pouvoir législatif la majorité
parlementaire à l'assemblée nationale en
tout cas au sénat s'est déporté n'oublie
jamais ça voilà un député de la majorité
a tendance à faire bloc avec le
gouvernement et ça c'est la 5ème
république qui le veut on sait bien que
le parlementarisme rationnalisé a fait
des dégâts dans la démocratie
parlementaire elle même thibault de
montbrial c'est commission denquête
finalement elle montre une chose c'est
qu'elles sont très suivi parce que c'est
le parlement qui contrôle l'exécutif et
non pas le parlement qui légifère
est-ce que c'est pas le signe qu'il faut
aller plus dans cette direction je crois
que ce qui vient d'être dit est vraiment
très intéressant parce que autant sur
les sujets de société sur lesquels n'y a
pas un impact qui va être un impact
politique qui risque d'être exploités
immédiatement avec peut-être une crise
gouvernementale etc
c'est quand même beaucoup plus simple
dans le système français et ça vient
l'indiqué très centralisé qui est qui et
où tout le monde se connaît c'est quand
même plus compliqué d'arriver à
s'extraire delà de la passion et la
pression politique pour prendre de la
hauteur
quand on est sollicité de toutes parts
pour peut-être et utiliser la commission
à mes fins politiciennes
par contre je le redis sur les sujets de
société pure et est ce que vous avez
fait sur ce dossier d'outreau sur cette
affaire d'outreau au sens large
ça me semble être un outil de démocratie
absolument merveilleux c'est finalement
une petite chose sur cette difficulté
quand les affaires sont politique c'est
vrai aussi comme le rapporteur est
systématiquement quasiment
systématiquement de la couleur de la
majorité
c'est lui qui tient la plume du rapport
à la fin il peut avoir tendance à
minimiser un peu les choses peut-être
qu'il faut être toujours que le
rapporteur ceux de l'opposition
et peut-être que
inquiète sur un petit peu plus on a déjà
on a déjà bien progressé parce que c'est
depuis la commission outreau qu' il y a
une règle non écrite en fait une règle
tacite qui veut que le président soit de
l'opposition et le rapporteur de la
majorité on pourrait inverser les choses
mais madame en kawa vous avez raison de
dire que le parlement est trop connue
sous son aspect de législateurs faire
les lois c'est important mais on en fait
trop des droits et pas assez sous son
rôle de contrôleur du gouvernement il
faut que le parlement légifère moins
qu'on fasse moins de lois mais qu'on
contrôle davantage ce que fait le
gouvernement
dernière question il ya une commission
denquête à l'oeuvre en ce moment
d'ailleurs à l'assemblée comme au sénat
s intéresse à la crise sanitaire et à la
gestion de la crise sanitaire par le
gouvernement est ce qu'on peut enquêter
sur une crise qui n'est pas terminée
moi je suis sceptique effectivement sur
la comment dire la possibilité pour mes
collègues de travail est actuellement
parce qu'on est en plein dans la crise
dans la deuxième vague mais dans la
crise sanitaire qui se prolonge
ces deux commissions d'enquêté ont été
créées à la fin de ce crew et la
dernière vague et la crise est toujours
là le virus est toujours là donc je
pense que le travail de difficile oui ça
illustre un vrai problème dans la
démocratie actuelle
au delà de ce que vous dites et que vous
avez tout à fait raison c'est qu'il ya
de plus en plus de gens qui déposent des
plaintes contre les ministres
dans la tempête c'est comme si on tirait
dans le dos du capitaine du bateau alors
que voilà et je pense que c'est
extrêmement dangereux parce que ça va
continuer à faire que les gens ne
voudront plus faire de la politique je
dis que lorsque la tempête n'est pas
fini il faut laisser des gens gérer ça
empêche pas de discuter de peu de
critiques etc
mais n'allons pas dans des processus
soit judiciaires soient parlementaires
qu'ils soient des processus de l'ordre
du procès avait dit attends donc merci
en quelques mots qu'est ce que vous avez
appris à vous plongez les dans toutes
ses archives
vous les journalistes événement en
quelques mois pour terminer j'ai appris
que cet exercice qui apparaît très
technique en fait de loin mais c'est des
moments très forts de télévision que ça
qui est étonnant c'est une dramaturgie
prg quelqu'un dit c'est vrai que la télé
réalité c'est à dire quelqu'un qui est
un puissant habituellement qui se
retrouve en position d'accusée qui se
retrouvent passés au crible par asthme
le député donc c'est un spectacle
télévisuel hassine entendu merci ça
s'appelle enquête au parlement enquête
au pluriel c'est à découvrir demain soir
sur lcp en direct à 21h la soirée des 20
ans c'est à 20h30 présenté par
jean-pierre gratien côté lcp rebecca
fitoussi
côté public sénat à ne pas manquer merci
messieurs merci andré vallini merci
thibault de montbrial quant à moi je
vous retrouve demain très belle forêt
[Musique]